hi I'm Erik Bosse and the upcoming
spider-man far from home is certainly
hiding a few tricks up its sleeve and
the most mysterious of them is
what's-his-name oh yeah Mysterio most of
us feel like we've gotten the guy
figured out ahead of time that there's
no way one of the most famous spider-man
villains is the nice guy apart from his
permit footage has suggested Jake
Gyllenhaal Quentin Beck claims to be a
hero from another reality in the
multiverse earth 83 11 and the monsters
that appear to be Sandman Hydra man and
multi man spilled in with him from that
reality to this one this guy's gotta be
lying about at least some of this stuff
right lying that he's a hero
probably but lying about the existence
of alternate realities at all
well considering now endgame left things
maybe not let's talk about Beck's
possible dishonesty about who he even is
spoiler warning the case the following
speculation ends up being a curative
ruins your life one super interesting
theory that a number of you have been
sharing with us is that Mysterio could
actually be Peter Parker from the future
now I initially dismissed this as just
too bonkers when it crossed my mind
months ago when I watched another movie
this year that featured a similar twist
not gonna say what it is in case you
haven't seen it but recently this theory
has come back to our attention from a
lot of you Owen over email several
others over Twitter and the more I think
about it it does and it's insanity kind
of makes sense let's talk through this
Quinton Beck Mysterio Peter from the
future well in the spider-man comics
Quinton Beck is a Hollywood special
effects technician and master
illusionist who weapon eise's smoke and
mirrors hypnosis toxic gas as opposed to
having actual superhuman abilities but
this movie version of Mysterio at least
from what we can tell from the far from
home footage released thus far doesn't
reference any of that backstory now it
could all be hidden behind it beside as
is often the case with Mysterio but
really if you look at it his tech seems
based on tech that we've seen in the MCU
before Iron Man esque repulsors and jet
propulsion assisted flight Doctor
Strange esque colors and shapes and his
energy blasts a Thor esque over-the-top
costume and armor this guy's all esque
following the tradition of Adrian Toomes
using scavenged Atari Tech to turn
himself into vulture and homecoming I
think it's pretty likely that this guy
could be doing something similar with
scavenged tech from or at least inspired
by the late Tony Stark but it's not like
a ton of stark Tech was just
around the wage Atari Tech was after the
Battle of New York stark famously kept
his technology pretty secure security
and responsibility with this weaponry
was his top priority after he returned
from his kidnapping the one hero with
access to stark stuff was Peter Parker
in fact the far from home footage
features him receiving special access to
Starks workshop where he builds a new
suit what if Peter using Tony Stark's
technology to build a new suit is more
than just a point of necessity or a rite
of passage with the young generation of
MCU heroes and harriday in that torch
carried by the old generation as we
pivot in the face for but if this whole
aspect of Peters suddenly gaining access
to the world's most valuable source of
technology and weaponry is the whole
point of the villains plot and far from
home but before continue thank you to
our sponsor curiosity stream for helping
us make this episode curiosity stream is
a subscription streaming service made
for those of you who have no shame in
your nerd game with over 2400
documentaries and nonfiction titles for
some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals with
content hosted by names like Sigourney
Weaver and Stephen Hawking personally
I've really enjoyed watching David
Attenborough's light on earth on
curiosity stream talks about a subject
that I'm super nerdily interested in why
some animals bioluminesce talk about you
fireflies creepy undersea creatures
why do you glow had it how does that
happen are these creatures communicating
are they blushing curiosity stream is
available worldwide on platforms like
Apple TV Roku iOS Android Xbox one
various Smart TVs chromecast Amazon fire
Amazon Kindle in web app get unlimited
access starting at just $2.99 a month
and for our audience the first 31 days
are completely free if you sign up at
curiosity stream comm slash new
rockstars and he's a promo code new
rockstars all one word lowercase no
quotes during the signup process ok back
to this Mysterio theory one thing I
noticed from the spider-man far from
home trailers is that Peter wears
multiple suits throughout the film we've
counted at least for his original one
from homecoming the Civil War the iron
spider armor from infinity war an end
game a new black stealth suit perhaps
given to him by Nick Fury and another
new one that he makes on the way to the
UK but
if Peter accidentally brought his
original suit with him to Italy as
footage has suggested why does he need a
new one
how and why does he lose his original
suit what if Peters original suit gets
stolen so BEC could try to
reverse-engineer Starks tech or maybe so
that Peter would have to get access to
Starks slab on Happy's jet to build a
new suit which could also expose that
lab and its resources to back in a past
trailer breakdown and point out how
weird it was that Happy's jet explodes
beside the Tower of London when there
are no visible projectiles or energy
blasts to strike it and caused that
explosion could the jet have been
sabotaged
internally by Beck after acquiring the
stark tech that he was after or could
the lab have self-destructed as a
security protocol by stark to prevent
thieves like Beck from breaking in
another interesting point Jake
Gyllenhaal was cast as Mysterio which
makes sense Gyllenhaal is a great actor
who tends to get brought up all the time
on superhero casting short lists but
long before that Gyllenhaal Batman
speculation last year Gyllenhaal
actually very nearly played Peter Parker
in Sam Raimi's spider-man 2 Tobey
Maguire was in a contract to speak with
the studio and Gyllenhaal was brought in
ultimately McGuire in the studio worked
things out but could Jake Gyllenhaal's
casting him far from home bring him full
circle with that Peter Parker history
just imagine an alternate branch history
in the MCU revealed from the timeline
Medlin of avengers endgame in which
Peter Parker has grown up in a world
post Tony Stark he gets access to all of
Starks weaponry and he uses that
technology to move on from the spider
sigil of his youth and adopt a new
identity Mysterio becoming the big star
learning how to manipulate the news
media and work the cameras but this
grown-up version of Peter Parker grows
isolated miserable perhaps he grieves
loved ones that he couldn't save and far
from home footage Beck does warn Peter
that sometimes the people he's trying to
save will die maybe he's hinting at his
alternate future where he lost MJ on May
when Stacy but then years later an event
ripples through the multiverse that
allows him to see how history played out
differently in alternate universes like
earth-616 he sees Peter 6-1-6 as a
chance to reset by entering that reality
becoming the stark like hero of this
reality stylishly defeating elemental
that he actually controls like puppets
sure this would require Mysterio to both
travel laterally across parallel
timelines and go back in time within the
timeline but assuming the Russo brothers
were right that cap grew old in a
separate timeline and then traveled back
to the end of endgame this kind of crazy
cosmic movement must now be possible in
the MCU so perhaps the real threat a far
from home is the Peter we know fighting
to keep Tony Stark's legacy out of the
hands of a villainous future version of
himself if this theory were true in I'll
admit it's a pretty wild one it would
explain quite a bit why Beck seems so
driven by a hero complex why he becomes
a mentor figure to Peter and why they
cast another actor who in many of our
imaginations was a perfect Peter Parker
and it would cast the movie's title
under a new light far from home wouldn't
just refer to Peter being far from
Queens New York on his trip to Europe it
could also refer to another Peter far
from his original home plotting to steal
someone else's comment down below with
your thoughts on this theory follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at EA Boston
subscribed in the rockstars of rebounds
everything spider-man related thank you
for joining me and as I said this
friendly mentor actually villainous
future self twist was actually in a
movie already this year and I don't want
to reveal which one in case we haven't
seen it but fine I'll tell you it was a
madea's family funeral dia was her own
greatest enemy
movies are a lot deeper than you think
[Music]